Наше завдання як держави — забезпечити
кожній дитині вільний доступ до знань
З цією метою у понеділок, 6 квітня, стартує
проект «Всеукраїнська школа онлайн»
В рамках проекту 40 педагогів з Києва на час карантину стануть вчителями для всієї України
Учні з 5 по 11 клас зможуть дистанційно вивчати 11 предметів за збалансованою програмою МОН
Щоранку з понеділка по п'ятницю уроки транслюватимуть українські телеканали
5 клас — канали «ПлюсПлюс» та «112 Україна»
6 клас — канали «Zoom» та «News One»
7 клас — канал «ZIK»
8 клас — канали «Індіго» та «Уніан»
9 клас — канали «Рада» та «UA:Культура»
10 клас — канал «UA:Перший»
11 клас — канал «М1»
Слідкуйте за розкладом уроків
Заохочуйте дітей до перегляду
та долучайтеся до пізнавального контенту
усією родиною
Залишаємось вдома!
Вчимось вдома!